Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes en la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
en el sur del Perú comunidades indígenas
mantienen una pugna en contra de los
yacimientos mineros por problemas
socioambientales el conflicto más largo
es el de las bambas una de las más
importantes minas de cobre del país
debido a estos conflictos los expertos
señalan que para el año 2023 las
inversiones programadas estarían
reduciendo en por lo menos dos mil
millones de dólares nuestro corresponsal
en Lima Francisco Zacarías es el autor
de este reporteros y nos acompaña hoy
para contarnos un poco más sobre ese
recorrido que hizo Por alguno de los
pueblos originarios que se mantienen en
pie de lucha Francisco les saludo porque
han surgido estos constantes conflictos
En Los Andes de Perú
herminia los conflictos sociales En Los
Andes de Perú en su mayoría están
relacionados al tema de la minería los
pueblos indígenas denuncian que hay
incumplimiento de contratos y demora en
la ejecución de algunos convenios por
parte de las empresas mineras también
existe preocupación referente a temas
ambientales relacionados a impactos en
la agricultura y en las fuentes de agua
pero también hay intereses económicos
por parte de algunos pueblos
relacionados al uso de sus sierras en
realidad los pueblos originarios señalan
que se sienten abandonados por un estado
que desde hace más de 30 años viene
aplicando una economía neoliberal que
prioriza la actividad extractivista como
generador de riqueza y esto les genera a
ellos
preocupación porque esta riqueza no se
ve reflejada denuncia en la
implementación de proyectos de reducción
de la pobreza y demás temas sociales eso
de ellos de interés ya volvemos con
Francisco aquí la historia
[Música]
en el sur del Perú comunidades indígenas
mantienen en jaque a yacimientos mineros
por problemas socioambientales el
conflicto más largo es el de las bambas
una de las más importantes minas de
cobre del país
Andrés huarcaya y su amigo realizan un
antiguo ritual a la madre tierra
le piden a los sapos espíritus
protectores de los incas que les ayuden
a recuperar los territorios ancestrales
porque ya no poseen tierras para vivir
ni sembrar si desean hacerlo deben pagar
150 dólares mensuales por el alquiler de
pequeñas parcelas ahora no puede sembrar
no puedes Por ejemplo acaso tenernos más
acá cuatro partes
vendieron 4.200 hectáreas también a las
bambas hace cinco años la empresa china
mmg trasladó una parte de la población a
Nueva fuerabamba donde construyó
viviendas y habilitó beneficios para los
comuneros la empresa incumple varios
acuerdos no les han terminado de pagar
180 hectáreas y reclaman porque la vida
que hoy tienen no es la misma que la
minera les prometió
Lamentablemente nos sentimos estafados y
estamos muy arrepentidos de haber dejado
nuestra tierra
la verdad Pero antes nosotros teníamos
pues lagunas teníamos para pescar así
libremente teníamos animales silvestres
teníamos subir para el cerro si quieres
ir a casar salías si quieres ir a pescar
también ibas al río teníamos toda la
libertad pero en este caso Ahorita
estamos limitados todos se quejan no
podemos ni ir al río y estamos metido
acá las bambas representa el 13% de la
producción de cobre del Perú en abril de
2022 los indígenas invadieron terrenos
de la minera por presuntos
incumplimientos de compromisos sociales
la empresa dijo que sufrió bloqueos por
más de 540 días que ocasionaron pérdidas
al Perú por 541 millones de dólares en
exportaciones y más de 77 millones de
dólares en impuestos los trabajadores
ejecutivos marcharon por algunas calles
del país para exigir al gobierno una
solución al conflicto alegando que no
deben nada las comunidades sin embargo
están dispuestos a sentarse a dialogar
las tierras han comprado hace años en
algunos casos hasta se han pagado
doblemente como el caso de Juan cuide
ellos alegan que hay no cumplimiento
compromisos nosotros lo que pedimos es
sentarnos en una mesa es parar la
violencia que no dejen operar y revisar
conjuntamente los conjuntamente con el
estado de las comunidades los
compromisos las comunidades de Vancouver
y fuerabamba son las comunidades
probablemente más beneficiadas por la
minería en todo el país todos tienen
derecho a empleo todos han recibido
fondos de manera importante
todos tienen inclusive becas han
recibido casas medios locales afirman
que la empresa compró en 2013 los
terrenos pagando más de 44 millones de
dólares y más de 30 millones de dólares
adicionales en 2017 pero una cláusula de
confidencialidad entre las bambas y las
comunidades no permite aclarar el
cumplimiento del contrato y
efectivamente esos acuerdos tenían
cláusulas de confidencialidad que la
empresa las puso porque no querían
que las otras comunidades se enteren de
cuáles habían sido los acuerdos yo creo
que eso ha sido un error no porque creo
que no se ha manejado con transparencia
y sobre todo la sensación que también a
uno le queda es que el estado peruano ha
renunciado a su rol a un rol que debe
ser de garante de hecho es decir no es
lo mismo Pues Cualquier relación entre
privados acá estamos hablando de una
relación entre una gran empresa minera
transnacional y comunidades campesinas
pueblos indígenas que finalmente logran
y firman convenios y acuerdos pero sin
la asesoría y el acompañamiento debido
son relaciones típicamente asimétricas
el yacimiento minero se encuentra en una
de las zonas más pobres del Perú su tasa
de pobreza asciende al 80% de la
población el 50% de los niños menores de
5 años padecen de desnutrición Crónica
según cifras oficiales
con la contaminación está muriendo
nuestra oveja porque
no se está apagando esta manera la
minera las bambas y por eso razón
estamos preocupados nosotros todas las
los comuneros y comuneras los campesinos
también denuncian que la mina generaría
un impacto negativo en la biodiversidad
local por el aire Es con a los
polvaderas
por el agua es en la cabecera de la
Cuenca es un tajo
por la tierra es por los nobles traen
los ácidos
[Música]
lo que tienen en ferrobamba y cuando la
lluvia cae esa lluvia ácida cae Entonces
al suelo lo penetra y
ya lo contamina con eso algunos
consideran que la empresa les pagó poco
por sus tierras y para compensar las
pérdidas Proponen el waki una
negociación que se remonta al tiempo de
los incas dijimos 50-50 pero
en la mesa queremos arreglar con la
minera las bambas Cuánto por ciento
podemos quedar de sus acciones o
utilidades en un inicio del Cobre se
trasladaría por un mineroducto de 206
kilómetros Ese fue el plan de la empresa
Suiza extrata antigua propietaria cuando
la compañía china mmg compró el
yacimiento decidió que el mineral
saliera por carretera y el gobierno
peruano reclasificó como ruta nacional
lo que eran vías vecinales los expertos
consideran que fue la razón que incendió
el conflicto las soluciones o la minera
china ASUME el costeo inicial de estrata
o que la minera china venda
su negocio porque lo ha hecho mal Eso es
un negocio o sea no viene por amor a la
naturaleza viene para hacer ganancia
había un plan de ganancias inicialmente
hecho por estrata
deciden reducir sus costos
resulta que por reducir sus costos ahora
tienen un conflicto social que asuman
los costos de crear un conflicto social
el objeto social no ha caído del cielo
movimiento social ha sido creado por
romper el acuerdo inicial que la firme
es trata firmó con las comunidades que
era poner un hidroducto vi compañeros
[Aplausos]
y en medio de este conflicto los
trabajadores mineros Ven peligrar a
9.000 empleos y el sustento para 75.000
familias detrás de Cada trabajador hay
una familia entera sueños que de repente
se estén postergando preocupación por
los estudios en curso que tiene nuestros
hijos qué va a pasar si todo esto se
paraliza no tenemos bastante
responsabilidad mucho de los compañeros
tienen hijos en universidades en
colegios en Jardines qué va a pasar para
poder sostener este este ingreso el
gobierno peruano instaló mesas de
diálogo entre los pueblos indígenas y la
empresa minera las bambas han
transcurrido meses de tensas
negociaciones que no satisfacen a las
comunidades campesinas
la defensoría del pueblo alerta que 218
conflictos sociales se registraron en
Perú de ellos 94 conflictos son mineros
según un funcionario del organismo el
estado peruano ejecuta acciones para
devolver la tranquilidad a las bambas
pero reconoce que aunque hagan tareas
pendientes la intervención del Estado
para atender los conflictos se ha
mantenido El problema es que hay una
falta de rendición de cuentas hay
compromisos asumidos pero no se no hay
una rendición de cuentas y una
transparencia de cuánto se ha avanzado
entonces consideramos que eso ayudaría
en buena medida a atender y enfrentar la
conflictividad y mientras más
información pueda haber pueda generarse
mejores condiciones para dialogar Pedro
Castillo ganó la presidencia con los
votos del Sur del Perú sus electores le
han venido exigiendo que solucionen los
problemas pero Casio no los Atendió
Richard Arce ha sido congresista por
Apurímac conoce la realidad de las
poblaciones indígenas y denuncia que en
el conflicto de las bambas existe un
aprovechamiento político el gran
problema es que acá hay una carga
ideológica supuestamente en campaña
Pedro Castillo recorrió todo el corredor
minero y ofreció nacionalizar los
proyectos mineros Ese es el punto de
partida de la irresponsabilidad y te
puedo demostrar ahora por qué Pedro
Castillo no regresa al corredor minero
va año y cuatro meses y no ha hecho ni
un solo viaje a chumbivilcas a espinar o
a cotabambas por qué porque él sabe en
su conciencia que no puede darle la cara
a los comuneros de esas poblaciones
porque era en campaña les ofreció
nacionalizar una medida totalmente
anacrónica que no corresponde justamente
a los acuerdos y compromisos que ha
establecido se requiere de la inversión
la dinámica de los mercados funcionan de
esa manera ojo esto no exime exigirle
altos estándares ambientales a las
empresas mineras que paguen sus
impuestos
debido a las protestas contra
yacimientos Mineros de enero a
septiembre el sector registró un
crecimiento negativo inferior al uno
punto cinco por ciento según cifras
oficiales de incertidumbre genera
repercusiones en los inversionistas
según declaraciones del señor presidente
de la sociedad Nacional de minería y
petróleo
ellos estiman
que para el año 2023 por esta
incertidumbre esta inseguridad las
inversiones programadas se estarían
reduciendo en por lo menos
dos mil millones de dólares debido solo
a esta inseguridad que despiertan no
estas protestas que el gobierno no puede
encontrarle solución adecuada los
pueblos indígenas esperan con ansiedad
la atención de sus demandas ambientales
sociales y económicas y si no encuentran
solución recrudecerán la lucha si
realmente la empresa también no pone de
su parte o no pone la voluntad de seguir
dialogando o de voluntad de solucionar
estos puntos que tenemos pendientes
Lamentablemente la comunidad está
esperando y si en cualquier momento se
puede reventar esto la sequía y la falta
de tierras para cultivar agotar una
paciencia de Andrés huarcaya hoy más que
nunca quiere retomar los terrenos
vendidos a la empresa minera
[Música]
no queremos problemas Eh no quiere comer
sino que cumple nada entonces queremos
volver los indígenas peruanos están
decididos a defender sus derechos y sus
territorios ancestrales y a luchar hasta
que sus fuerzas lo permitan de no
conseguir que la minera les restituya lo
que reclaman traspasaran a sus hijos la
contienda
estamos de nuevo con Francisco Zacarías
autor del reportero que acabamos de ver
Francisco las comunidades indígenas
llegarán a aceptar acuerdos que proponga
el estado y la minería
Bueno en realidad el estado peruano está
impulsando mesas de diálogo entre las
comunidades indígenas y las empresas
mineras Pero existe desconfianza muchas
comunidades indígenas señalan que todo
queda en promesas Y esto es respaldado
por la defensoría de pueblo de ese país
que señala que el 47% de los acuerdos no
se cumplen por falta de un impulso
político desde el sector del gobierno y
justamente al no cumplirse estos
acuerdos genera conflicto como el de las
bambas que la población está reclamando
desde hace meses un entendimiento con la
empresa minera china mmg precisamente la
presidenta Dina boluarte Está tratando
de implementar una agenda ambientalista
donde la actividad relacionada a la
extracción de oro plata co no se
sobreponga sobre el agua vamos a ver si
la presidenta boluarte tiene éxito en
esta gestión que trata de unir a las
comunidades indígenas a las empresas
privadas para generar calma y alentar
tanto a la inversión nacional como la
extranjera Gracias Francisco por
acompañarnos el día de hoy hasta aquí
reporteros a la semana recuerde que para
sintonizar esta y las emisiones
anteriores puede visitar nuestro sitio
web France 24.com hasta la próxima
[Música]